on
[Musique]
n'a pas ça en france pourquoi on a passé
en france voir venir dans les pays de
l'est qui vont se briser ce jour en
france voilà on passe un cap dans un
lieu mythique le hollywood de bulgarie
ce clip là qu'on n'en voit c'est trop
grave j'ai jamais vécu ça c'est
hollywoodien cherchent à retenir est
officiellement sur la mobilité
l'architecte qui tient les ficelles
tueur et cesc parentis n 3 dans tout ce
qui sort de la mine pour autant et je
les mains sales
bienvenue dans la ville de sofia
je ne connais rien sur cette ville je
peux même pas aider un truc si la
monnaie s'élève à ok j'en avais une
blague d'en bloquer aujourd'hui à
cracher sur un peu jaloux quand quand le
mec du kebab y avait quelqu'un d'autres
chefs on sait bien qu'il est réservé
pour moi
tiens ça qu'ils appellent google
merci merci mais qu'il a fait le vide
jarry en vacances à la sortie un peu de
pain une première fois pour la bulgarie
bah oui qui albanais alket de cette
vidéo
il est avec nos accords bien sûr
cela ne s'est pas montré les deux merci
de moncrabeau irez-vous à personne si
vous combinez ces vendredi
les traîtrises
j'avais l'impression que la promesse
était toujours 24 avec orelsan tous les
médias que 24 heures c'était la même
barre de vie il a fait pareil non j'ai
fait ça on n'a pas fait 24 ans un record
est-ce que la journée de la saison avec
les tristes les bâtards
je veux changer
ce
seuil on leur donne excluait g10
offriront venez allez vous rezé on joue
un peu bonjour minecraft fait le tour
des pièces
pause-café ce commandant trovic cinq
journées
journée pour lever et une faute dans l
allée goodbye
tu sais le dire aux bulgares c'est à
dire sans oublier à montfaucon s'arrête
honte à moi
[Musique]
rome sous la neige c'est un beau bébé
l'as rome en carton j'ai souvent vite à
un combat de gladiateurs
romains de décors dans lesquels
pas mal pas mal alors est ce que c'est
ce qu'on va utiliser pour ça il aurait
fallu lire le sino d'halluciner autres
personnes la lutte continue et on sait
pas à quoi ressemblent les réelles pour
les a jamais
bien
on s'entend très bien avec cette
production
des jeux je suis content que vous
existiez vraiment parce que
je suis tombé sur 10 km carottes
fr
nous lâcher la grappe brut
comptez pas sur moi pour m'aider pour
vous dire j'adore ça je vais mettre ça
en passant que vous attendez
on va attendre partie-cycle
j'ai aucun avis moi j'ai envie de vous
dire je vous suis c'est vous les
artistes
lève ton verre
tu fais bien
[Musique]
aldebaran vers ici doivent pas manger
les restes
des jeunes aucune
elle a commencé avec et arnold allez on
voulait pas glander 107
décor
barrabes
de barack ses codes ses disques à la
demande intérieure vous avez déjà fait
au moins deux morts
non mais je te vois bien faire d'escale
à de hautes fonctions dans les délires
de sport
enseigner c'est une salle de sport pour
faire du sport de la
presse et de la détermination la
place à la toile et bouquets un truc
pourquoi il ya une pause il à la salle
enfin si ça c'est un certain mindset
voilà date de médias dans ce gamin
fais danser
mais là c'est
rezaï à de la vraie boufferez rossa
d'après vous
l'odeur
ça sent la saucisse
des frites et
tu as bien fait je vais revenir bruit
ah les [ __ ]
tâche dans la
nouvelle grille vasseur
ah bah non les autres c'est le bon
chemin on est indépendant et souverain
on extrait les pierres de la montagne
comme avant mais là c'est nous qui avons
tous les tons très large à pied mais
finalement mon retour et je saigne ou
carrément marquée par dix ans comme
c'est pas gagné d'avancé finito
il va revivre
ça ce couple
quant à elle dans la cage
ça c'est magouille de compagnies
comme la tête ce matin ouais quelle
séquence j'avais des frissons tomber
dans le coup comme les mecs dans facteur
x avec des insectes mais moi c'était des
frites ces batailles mettre la pression
parce qu'il met tellement de préparation
enfin si tu rates pas prise tu sens tu
t'emmerdes tout le monde et que tu as
regardé beaucoup de gens bonjour j ça ça
aussi c'est un truc de ouf comme un
coucou on fait d'une telle organisation
pourquoi ci fut c'est beau
salut aux tendances
mais tunisie
ou sur la nidation jusqu'à 20 minutes de
vidéo
il ya que les humains pour faire des
trucs comme ça
en plus que les gens comprennent pas du
tout à musique qui comprennent pas le
français aucune idée justifie qu'on
entend de faire mais j'ai bien peur aux
personnes perdent ils le répètent entre
les prises je les entends
monter la mayonnaise qu'on s'assoit dans
la société - les chefs c'est bien fait
ça dans son fief faire sourire si
personne te respecte si ta meuf que pour
ce que tu restes avec système parce
qu'elle a vu des paillettes n'a plus
qu'à prier qu'elle croit jamais trek aux
victimes tout n'importe quel mec pas sur
elle et elle a fallu remplacer tous mes
rêves tout ce qui les intéresse
démontage de la fa temps sur
2,1
en dormir mais retraité fait la visite
de sofia en bulgarie tous les lieux
touristiques
c'est fou on a postulé fin ça me
rappelle un truc c'est clair c'est la
prison américaine ah ouais ouais je sais
avec de l'autoroute les mecs de los
toros alès ça tombe bien c'est le moment
nouveau
mais c'est là l'ami steve consorzio avec
valdes les mecs de l'autoroute a13 greg
quoi l'être audio garizim position il ya
des gens
attention à tes yeux partout où tu as
des bâtons c'est d'être où il aimerait
qu'ils vont sortir aucun état position à
toi allez voir vous allez vers les
escaliers dans l'après les plans
suivante donc l'idée c'est que les
pendant le jeu we die hard top donc vous
rappelez vous éviter un peu les zombies
et quand je vous dis top on partait un
peu dans cette direction donc juste
offert un peu ton chemin tu vois c'est
comme ça pour les éviter eric de vous
sortir derrière mais vous partez par là
on va en faire une fois voir
chaque année dans sa position
solar et fort oui
bonjour
[Musique]
j'ai mangé
former les gens mangeaient 320 que celle
en fait trop
même enchaîné j'enchaîne
l'ancien trop bien
par contre tu vas pas donner le top
qui a dit que j'étais au fond du trou
que avez raison on a un groupe de rap
gothique avec valdes
ckoi ne place de rapts ixic ne
pas de slip
depuis trois ans pour le remettre
je
[Musique]
suis content je regardais brut je suis
trompé de caméras auquel elle est volée
[Applaudissements]
this
way fait pester chaque début de journée
je veux qu'on est tous négatifs
normalement il n'y a pas de raison que
ont sorti mais on sait jamais
il ya toujours un petit suspense parce
que si je suis positif qu'est ce qu'on
fait
c'est ça la question
avant le plus lourd ah ouais
m aulas de tourner si tôt dans le froid
et sous le poids de savate sait plus se
lever de bonne heure qui moi
qui me tire un peu sur la tronche
arrivant dernier ce matin en
arrivant dernier
je crois que tu mens je comprends pas à
quelle époque on est
ici c'est vraiment ça
l'a bien fait mais la tendance vous êtes
mort je sais au mont blanc qui est déjà
mère ou du taux directeur
pour cela la voilà
mais
donner mon boivent
[Musique]
1 et quel décor
j'essaie d'être le plus gênant possible
suit la veille
[Musique]
toutefois m
la drogue
et on est où là
c'est chaud deux des quatre
grosses promos ce produit
non mais non pas 5 arte et beaucoup
souhaité tourner ici on fait les
différents en beaux ils ont fait
les exploits des bleus l'a
fait des mauvais films avec un bâtiment
et regarder
on fait beaucoup
dans un lieu mythique hollywood de
bulgarie touche ok de plus
accessoire au même endroit turin bus
comme ça incroyable points coeur
des voitures de police
incroyable il ya une cabine téléphonique
incroyable tout est pas si les mains
lui son truc incroyable
des gens qui font des crêpes aux
lutteurs
amis ni ses bois sur un journal chinois
shi pays de doc et je vois des
primipares c'est sur ce match va
nous
michael jackson tu lafuma pas le seul
film après jackson
incroyable bo s'est incliné vos sorties
si j'étais elle
quartiers bouclés johnny rends toi
ou sinon on va envoyer une méga chi de
crash fruno à toi c'est la folie new
york mais kanye west side story tout ça
waouh jeudi les décors salue
la sécheresse n'a pas retrouvé les
accessoires les voitures
trop de lumière c ou c ou au niveau
les escaliers de secours des américains
faisaient comme nombre de morts
sophie sur la 32e
expendables
mais on va faire des maxi totaux à
claques
c'est un mytho tu peux faire le mec qui
voyage beaucoup
je vais faire une content parce que non
ça je pourrais tu vois j'ai pas vouloir
tisser jamais tu me crois qu'un jour
j'ai eu une embrouille avec ça
que je sais
c'est qu'en saison oui voilà ce
qu'est ce que vous avez dit sur mon
album
dans ces choses qui sont faut chercher
des moyens hollywoodiens de bordeaux n'a
dit que c'est qu'elle s'est tournée ou
pas welch et dans un liner soudan un des
meneurs et je sors je me met des claques
à moi même et après je suis accroché
j'ai accroché parce que je vais être
accroché la vallée
chaque clip cyan hauteur je sais pas
pourquoi
c'est toujours un moment où je suis en
hauteur des objets vertige
mais j'aime bien moi je suis content
c'est frais c'est un peu
en manège sur nes
des 20 points dans le guide des mots
claude spécifiquement maintenant tous
sont
des passionnés ici
[Musique]
l'effort c'est déjà une composition
différente
au classement
cette action pour ses responsables
mais simple
eh bien allez on se casse
on vient pas
mais
les françaises voilà ça c'est le tien
ici c'est qu'elle en paraît
vraiment pas trop je pense que ça va
chier pour moi ils vendent après
qu'un début et la fin et au plus à ce
bac en plus ça se voit que tout est
précieux
longtemps on fait des tableaux deux
temps donne
dépêche toi j'ai des choses à faire je
suis toujours sur un nouvel album
bien le mien celui des rêves celui de
bdl celui diony das sa bosse aussi la
prochaine groupe m6 a décliné
les deux volets
j'arrive 3 or
regarde
grosse parodie
moi tout à l'air hazardous frais
sans doute et un mode de convoquer
d'abord toasted sandwich ça peut prendre
un petit temps par mois 9 g 1 5 6 10
un peu de fromage pour un a fait pour
que les ingrédients colle bien tu vois
qu'il soit bien sûr mon chèque c'est
l'équivalent de 2 à devient genre
de samsun appelez
moi
c'est du tungstène
sert pour se leurrer un bon sandwich
cgc des oignons avec je suppose que
c'est d'ailleurs le sommes
ok j'ai dit non
sinon
perfect un sens du jeu parfait dont je
vais vous le résumé philadelphia ton un
truc vert et des contenus encore
si
je vais faire confiance aux tons
je sens bien pour
philadelphia
du ton
cocon beurre
little people
just
un défi magnifique el may be somalienne
oui faut ce
jeudi richelle son squad et biz blanche
sur white sens
bien eyebe eyebe
l'impression reste aujourd'hui sur cette
journée de 14 heures jusqu'à nier plus
j'ai peur de coeur s'arrête pas mal
sur le plan technique non c'est un plan
technique ils sont bien débrouillés
j'ai trouvé les zombies
ils ont su mettre une part d'humanité on
sent fière c'est pas des zombies
classiques y avait vraiment des zombies
qui qui luttent entre côté monstrueux
côté salut
la grande famille on a pensé à apprendre
du champagne pour ce soir alors
d'indigents l'année jour
ça va être le meilleur nous la grappe va
te faire tester
qu'ils soient positifs sur le tournage
même
c'est là où ils ont tué harry potter
3 justine pas porte
afa sorte ne tient pas devant brut ouais
faut le dire faut le dire aux
téléspectateurs
ces écoutes ont suivi de tempête mais ce
que tu as vu cette lampe de chevet
incroyable
film sous la lampe de chevet les
conditions de travail sont désastreuses
qu'est ce que tu veux savoir comment on
commence à trouver comment vous êtes
retrouvé sur ce mensonge si la connexion
n'est pas elle n'est pas nouvelle
j'étais déjà sur l'album de grains
universo et il faut arrêter
et je dit vas-y vivante et un son et on
l'a un jour j'arrive au magasin
universal qui vont des instruments de
musique
et
et la joue un mec en face et je le dis
c'est valdes
et voilà c'était marrant c'est croiser à
universal ont séduit faut qu'on passe un
son pour l'album et voilà et on pourquoi
pourquoi seulement payant payons pas ce
que c'est les premières unités d'un work
as 3 et c'est ce qu'ils vont chercher du
minerai toute leur vie et c'est un
questionnement métaphysique est ce que
on est condamné à aller chercher du
minerai toute notre vie est ce que c'est
ça le but de la vie il ya toujours le
mit tout genre ouais je vais percer à
presse avec les vacances et s'échappa
bientôt les vacances ne s'est jamais
vacances ça parce que tu disais déjà
quand tu dis quand est-ce que ça
s'arrête grave
après faut réussir à maintenir le truc
apprête à plus d'une opportunité tu te
dis mais je peux pas laisser passer ça
c'est trop gros dur c'est toujours une
sorte de fenêtre et de chance et on peut
pas laisser passer ouais exactement
et après en plus c'est encore plus dur
de maintenir le level parce que tu l'as
déjà fait a pu la fraîcheur des fois on
se dit bon
est ce qu'on ferait pas mieux d'aller à
la plage enfin j'ai ce sentiment des
bagarres ce qu on s'essouffle pas aussi
tu vois mais qu'est ce qu'on ferait
d'autres je crois je me ferais chier
aussi à la plage peut-être
sommes nous condamnés
à travailler sans cesse qui doit on peut
pas dire ou ne pas dire nos moutons
génial et en même temps insupportable
souvent secrètes car en train de mendier
et là tu sais que ça baisse un peu genre
cette semaine je parle a vendu que onze
mille disques l'année c'est pas une vie
c'est pas une vie
jusqu'ici pour ce mur en briques
spécialement ce qu'on veut pendre la
texture ans on n'avait pas n'arrivez pas
à voir la texture de ce mur en briques
donc on a dû venir jusqu'ici à sofia en
bulgarie ils ont fabriqué le mur et on
est là mais venez juste pour se muer
mais on a mis les petits plats dans les
grands je te le dis en brut en scoop 3h
du mat des grottes
et je crois qu'on a exploité le studio
j'avais depuis longtemps et travailler
que ces jeunes garçons
on a un peu donné le maximum quoi il y
avait des corps comme à hollywood en
fait
apportez de l'avion
new york et rome et tout ce que tu veux
donc en fait c'est un peu les rangs pour
les réalisateurs le script est écrit sur
cette base la route c'est à s'amuser à
traverser le monde du cinéma et à
travers toutes les poursuites et vos
films donc c'est ça l'idée un peu de
venir ici donc je le conseille à tous
participer
bravo brut merci d'avoir participé à
cette grande fête audiovisuelle merci
beaucoup g 3d où c'est le monde prend la
poudre d'escampette
[Musique]